so what a really cool event hosted by
this company called carrot they provide
these metal credit cards to creators and
influencers they invited us to this
event and there are tons of super cool
people here and we decided we'd try
something different for this episode
we're gonna have a bunch of people swing
by just random really cool influencers
or business people like nate o'brien ask
sebby a bunch of people and they're all
just gonna have little segments on here
talking about some really fascinating
tidbits of information yeah now the fun
part about this is that we're filming
this at the very end and i have to say
these 20 minutes that we have with with
each person
is in my opinion
like but it's so good because we have to
be so like fast paced
sometimes i think this is more
interesting than like an hour-long
episode so you guys are really going to
enjoy it as soon as you subscribe yeah
subscribe you just got it hit the
subscribe patreon too oh yeah we got the
patreon yeah check out many things guys
okay they're all going to be linked down
below we're going to have tons of really
cool guests on thank you so much cara
for throwing this event and inviting us
and let's get on with the episode so
coming on right now we have mink she is
a massive twitch streamer and she also
participated in creator clash she
dominated the event and uh she's
incredibly interesting so we're going to
have her on right now there we go just
bite it
that's that's perfect it tastes good um
tastes like a aluminium no it's the
other way it's it's where it says audio
technica hello yeah that was good hello
that's it hello that's good okay welcome
right there to the ice coffee hour my
name is minks and i'm here with my two
guests
wow cool we are the guests that's just
fantastic welcome to my podcast we're
not streaming today i'm happy to have
you here so you're a streamer i am how
did you get started in that i liked
games i liked video games i used to play
crash bandicoot as a kid on the ps2 bit
of hercules sometimes
and then
as a little side hobby i started twitch
and
for seven years was a 10 viewer andy
with absolutely nothing
playing video games dead by daylight
call of duty everything
and then i went on a dating show called
lover host and it changed everything so
you did it for how long uh i started
maybe i should even pull out my old
youtube videos i started as a kid i
always wanted to be in content creation
but you know especially when you're from
ireland you don't expect to succeed it's
it's one in million chance for anyone
regardless but a loud irish girl
from ireland
making it here in l.a made it though
look at me mom i'm on a podcast right
now sorry got sidetracked jack
nonetheless i've adhd could you repeat
the question
what was the question oh how did you get
started and you said you were streaming
for seven to ten people for years and
then you were on a dating show yes blew
up i just i would play games like dead
by day like call of duty on my own with
my friends when i was younger and then
a guy called austin austin show he
found a clip of me
spilling ketchup on my shirt and instead
of changing it
i just turned the shirt backwards
and was like well it's clean now and he
thought that was funny and he invited me
to his show lover host which is you go
on um it's not discord it's not skype
there's another one
there's one of those things stream yard
no it's like zoom
yeah i think it was before yeah zoom
zoom okay there was one before that's to
say it's discord whereby yeah whereby
that was it sure and then you just go on
there and he'd have a guy and have 20
women
fight over that guy and then it was
always a big streamer so like
i guess i was just loud and crude and
that blew me up what did you say like
what clip went viral of that you must
have said something i would just call
the other because i was
i'm not mean to women but they were my
enemy at the time because i was fine for
the guy's love
and i guess the c word here
isn't really
popular so i would continuously call
them that if they would get ahead of me
and i'd get mad and throw my chair
around and then a lot of people were
like oh
she's a bit insane and she let's uh just
click on her and watch her more and then
i went from 10 viewer to 200 viewer andy
and then from that i had more
opportunities people reached out to me
and had me on their shows too and it
just kept growing but if you're asking
about uh my biggest clip
it would be the dreaded white claw clip
what is the dreaded white clock lip i
was um
i'm not gonna call it cosplaying i'll
say dressing up because i looked nothing
like kanata from naruto but i was
dressed up as her and i had a little
shuriken and i was just flipping it
around it was plastic by the way so i
didn't expect it to actually hit the
white claw
i stabbed the white cloth sprayed me in
the eye i got blinded i screamed and ran
off and that got like 2.4 million
views
just from that clip and this was when i
was still
smaller like 200 viewers and then it
just
kept going from there so you found that
by like kind of acting out or doing
these obscene things that you got
viewers and you're able to catapult that
then to
twitch
yep and then it just kept going and i
kept being more psycho and then i
moved to l.a six months ago and i was
like
it's gonna be temporary but the
opportunity's here
but you're all like no offense to
americans love you guys love you guys
you're a bit
not funny americans aren't funny yeah
are we trying to be funny though i don't
think we're just you just don't get
irish humor i said clint on the [ __ ]
train going to disneyland and a woman
looked at me as if i was like the devil
and i was like okay i think that's just
a little bit more normalized like over
in like that place yeah to be fair it's
the irish place
geography wise europish you know that's
common no the irish are a [ __ ]
yeah it's not really a word that you say
here like in the u.s a bit of a
stigmatized word it's it's not this is
it's just like really really abrasive or
something i think so it's shocking for
people to hear that's why they hear that
they don't know how to react it kind of
like stuns them it's a lady's part but
we can say
and no one blinks an ayat it is kind of
interesting how we just pick and choose
what words are like the worst ones and
whatever it really is let's get back to
your successor okay would you say that
the person that you acted on camera was
that strategic in order to get these
viral moments to help catapult your
career to success or is that like
actually kind of an accurate reflection
of who you are on a daily basis and it
just so happens that like people really
like that uh
i would say a mix of both because at the
time i was working a full-time job as a
receptionist
um
and then
i'd like to just
have fun but this sounds sad i didn't
have many friends in ireland i was an
introvert back then surprise look at me
now on a podcast well i was an introvert
so i would try show my
fun crazy side to the
internet and do that so yeah it's
definitely a power of me and it's ever
since i moved to la i realize it's a
bigger part of me than i thought
because i've not been as introverted
since but
no it's
probably just mental illness to be
honest like i i i don't think uh
or the irish it's either the irish in me
or the mental illness in me could be
both though yeah
probably on the good side
i succeeded a tiny bit
not yet no you've succeeded a lot a lot
actually can you talk about finances at
all
are you comfortable talking about that
oh i thought you were going to ask me
like advice on finance i was like man
i'm really dumb
i don't we can talk about that too oh
yeah we could go over that but i'm
curious like from your perspective in
terms of like your income and how that's
shifted
so it
went from
you know i was working
50 hours a week as a receptionist for a
more company by the way would give out
headstones tough job actually because
you'd come in and they'd just be sobbing
to you because they're buying a
headstone for someone that's dying or
dead and i'd be like
it'll be 400 plus taxes yeah yeah no no
no it starts at 2 600. 2 600.
that was for the limestone one and then
if you wanted to go to grana and there's
different colors
and i'd just be like
it's a lot of money for you i know and i
know you just lost someone but my boss
will kill me if i don't sell you the
best
headstone out here my boss was a bit of
a like he was like no just show them and
i'm like they're here crying about their
last ones that job was
and it was funny because we it wasn't
funny we also
sold counter stops because it was like a
countertops it was a granite company so
when someone would come in
i wouldn't know if they were going to
come in
and be sobbing for a headstone or a new
family excited to get their first
countertop in their new house so i'd see
someone i'd be like
hold the face like this hold it but no
that job was paying me
1 500 to 2 000 a month
depending on my hours
um the hours started at 40 and then i
realized when i started which happened
and i remember getting my first paycheck
and it was like
well not my first one but when i started
growing and it was 3.5 k and i was like
i can just act the idiot online
instead of
sitting
at this headstone company for
40 hours a week
and make more money and then my dad was
the most supportive one in that
my mom was always because i went to
college to be a special needs assistant
for three years
um so the headstone company was like
just a stepping stone
and then i was like i don't wanna
do prison officer or special needs
assisting when
i can just like be myself and be a
weirdo and
somehow get paid more
somehow get paid more that was insane
but first we gotta thank our sponsors
storyblocks guys we've been using
storyblocks for about two years now and
i mean it when i say it has helped the
workflow of this business tremendously
storyblocks is a subscription service
that gives you instant access to
millions of high-quality royalty-free hd
and 4k footage templates images sound
effects you name it i cannot tell you
the countless hours i've literally just
wasted looking for the perfect stock
footage or sound effects for my edit
well with storyblocks that is no longer
an issue i've been able to reinvest this
time i've saved from storyblocks back
into my creative visions and to make
content that i'm truly proud of and
whether you're part of a large media
company or just trying to jumpstart your
next creative passion project
storyblocks is the perfect solution with
your flexible and scalable subscription
plans you could start creating content
with the tools you need without having
to worry about a budget plus their
unlimited all-access plan lets you
downloaded unlimited assets from all
three of their libraries guys seriously
we've been loving and using storyblocks
for about two years now and we are so
excited that they reached out to sponsor
us creative burnout is a real thing and
creative inspiration does not have to be
so taxing learn more about how you can
take your editing to the next level when
you visit storyblocks.com
ich again that's storyblocks.com
ich or you could just use the link down
below in the description thank you so
much storyblocks and back to the podcast
and what about today how is that evolved
can you share how much yeah so i
i
right now like my most recent paycheck
on twitch was
8.6 k
but the issue with that is
because the brits took half of the irish
land
i get taxed sixty percent on everything
so
even no more even though i'm making a
lot of money at the end because ireland
doesn't have a treaty with america like
uk does the the top have not northern
ireland does so i'll pay
twitches tax i'll pay
irish tax and i'll pay la tax
and it all bundles off where it totals
to 60 percent
so i do make good money but more than
half of it gets taken do you find that
demotivating though like why am i doing
all this work when i get to keep 40
it is when the tax time comes around and
i see my friends paying way less
but it's also like
i still have this insane opportunity
like even with the amount of tax i pay
it's better than what i was doing in
ireland yeah but it's just a bit
annoying now what about other
opportunities sponsorships endorsements
are you doing those yeah so my agent
daniel he
he has brought up i used to work oh no i
won't say names because it'll make them
look bad but i used to work with three
different sponsor companies
and they'd bring stuff to me in a
discord channel and
my sponsor
when i got sponsored it'd be around
to
3k per sponsor
and then when i was at my peak and
blowing up i remember my biggest one and
i was like oh my god thank you prime
video shout out to you baby
but then i got cancelled and
it dropped down to i would be lucky if i
got 1k for a sponsor no what do you mean
you got cancelled
um i'm out i'm out of the loop are you
able to talk about this yeah i know i
can talk about it so
in ireland
it's different there so
i said i didn't realize that
the l word was a slur for lesbian i
didn't realize that was a slur at the
time and i because i have
very gay friends in ireland that would
say it normally and then i sit on stream
and this was when i was blowing up with
the minecraft community and they can be
a bit finicky with
and they
almost kind of like kept saying in chat
they're like you can't say that and i
was drunk at the time i was like i can't
say
the answer okay i'm like but it's for
it's for a lesbian and they were like
no that's a slur towards lesbians and
i'm like
i'm more gay than i am straight i'm like
i didn't even realize this i didn't mean
it like that but they kept taking that
clip of context and they would post all
over tick tock saying that i was just
kind of degrading and then that was the
start of it
and then they dug up tweets from 2015
when i was a teen where i was like i
prefer asians over white boys
and it they said i was f
fetish child i can't say the word
fetish
thing yeah you can't say it all i can
say
fetishizing and then that just blew up
more on tick tock and they kept going
and then
even if you look at my tic toc comments
now like if i post something it'll be
like oh isn't this the homophobic and
i'm like bro i'm gay i was a closeted
[ __ ] gay for years because ireland's
[ __ ]
still
moving on but
that just brought my
sponsors down because anytime my name
would be mentioned it was oh my god a
bad thing about it was this recent um no
this was like
last year
but it still comes to
this day and then that's what i was
saying back to the sponsors
um
the three companies i worked with just
kind of stopped bringing me stuff to
wait for it to blow over
and then luckily my current agent when i
came out here
uh miko hooked me up with him and he was
like it's that's not why your price went
down it's because you were working with
three different people and they were
giving out different prices
and but the whole time i thought it was
because
i was like oh i'm a bad person
but he was like no it's because three
different and then he brought my price
and now
my recent sponsor was
a for a pac-man thing which
when i thought that was the end of me is
a really
good thing to get back up there i'm sure
we've all done or said something at some
point and good gosh can do silly things
all the time and something that's like
silly can just be misconstrued as like
oh that's your intention you're trying
to hurt these people or whatever but i
don't know i mean especially you just
you said that you're les you're a
lesbian i am
like you're like mostly
i'm pansexual prefer women what if uh
i meet a guy that has the same
the it's personality for me okay but i
prefer women
it's a weird thing i'm scared to even
say my sexuality because i
never wanted to label myself i said i
don't want a label
and then at the time they were like no
if you like everybody your pan your pan
and i'm like okay i'm pansexual then
and then one day i was like i think i
prefer women and they're like that means
you're not panned because
you're open to everyone and i'm like at
the time you were you were the one that
put the label on i was just like i like
who i like yeah it's it's a weird thing
so the internet can be scary at times
especially because you know you're
figuring out stuff on your own
you're
changing and then someone will come or
similar back to
i don't know if you guys played xbox
i played ps3
back in those days
the [ __ ] that was said on the mic it
just it just it's i don't like when
they dig up stuff from the past
and they don't let people change
yeah it's kind of same with jenna
marbles the stuff like that where
she apologized but they won't let go but
then they missed her when she was gone
it's like
yeah the internet but i will say the one
thing i really admire about you is how
competitive you are at just how
resilient you are no matter what happens
you keep you keep coming back
and
you you your fight i think was a great
example of that at the boxing ring i was
shocked between you and yodeling hayley
that was in my opinion the most like
gut-wrenching fight for me to watch as
well
i think that was that takes the entire
thing for the entire boxing match was
watching youtube yeah 100 i was like i
could because i couldn't do that like
straight up
if you put me in that situation i'd i'd
be out so fast i was so impressed by her
because so uh i don't remember we would
have like group training things yeah
people would meet up
haley was always very hidden to the
point my coach would be like she's not
taking it serious and then at the end he
was like no i met her coach and she's
taking this
very serious she gave up vaping she and
i was like
i'm scared i'm scared but i did not
expect her to because i had contacts in
and in the first round she knocks out
one of my contacts and i remember being
half blind and i'm like
oh my god
i thought when i was gonna fight a tick
tocker it was gonna be over in one throw
no
she was
she was strong everyone was saying that
she wasn't like
hitting me but she was it was like
i was dazed like i
neither of us really remember the fight
and she just kept going and kept going
and then the second no the third round
she knocked out my other contact so it
was just a blurry vision and at that
time i thought she was gonna
kill me because between like not being
able to see and
every time she'd come back there's one
clip of her where she's bleeding down
the nose and she's like
and i was like if i'd seen that i would
i
people didn't see it with my coach i was
saying to him that i think i need to tap
out i couldn't breathe i was losing it i
was like i can't breathe and he's like
you got this you got and i'm like oh my
god my dad's watching and every time i
went back up and then even when i the
fourth round when i won
you can actually see me in the video
not realizing i won i was so dazed i was
so out of it that when i heard that bell
i thought it was about to go to the next
round and i sat down they gave me water
and my coach is like you did it and i
was like i won i won and everyone in the
clip was like she walked off so
confident mm-hmm
i was i thought you did
i was no i was just like
keep going keep going
and then i went up back to the room and
hurled everywhere in the toilet really
yeah when they brought me back like even
on the winning scene i was like trying
to be funny but i was like oh my god
just let me back in the room i'm gonna
how'd you feel the next day amazing
really
no i did feel amazing at the time i was
like when i felt that pain from the hits
and like
they're like oh my god what happened i
was like never again and then
no it wasn't even the next day it was
after i hurled and i stood up and i was
like that was the best experience of my
life
what did you like about it i just
like
boxing because it's a place where
you can be feral
you can be fair on they're not gonna but
it's a safe way that the the rest will
stop it when they're worried but you
don't have to worry about holding back
and you don't have to worry about your
opponent like if you get in a bar fight
banter is going to take you away
straight away but in the ring you can
just boo
boo and it's the energy it's the fitness
gained a lot of weight since that fight
haven't worked out in two months but
i'll get back into it soon but at that
time it was just it's
boxing is yeah
are you going to continue doing the
boxing training yeah
yeah definitely it was
i don't know why because i like looked
back and i'm like oh i almost lost but
it was still one of the most thrilling
things i've ever experienced in my life
do you think you would do it again
absolutely so if ian comes back to you
says creator clash two
you in you'd say yes absolutely really
absolutely is there anybody that you
would want to fight in particular
so
i don't know how much i can say but they
already have been looking at someone for
me and she terrifies me really she
terrifies me and it was funny because we
went to spotify close down disney
recently and i walked into her and i
like was like hey she's so nice she's
the sweetest girl ever
but she
scares me with the like haley i didn't
know much about her i was like tick tock
or easy but the fact that i almost lost
that and i'm already scared of this one
and i'm like
maybe i uh
maybe we should just uh
because a lot of people wanted to get
into creator clash yeah they wanted to
go into it after you know how big it was
last time
and ian and anisa has to choose from so
many content creators so no one's
confirmed except for two matches
they confirmed mine straight away and i
was like i don't mind giving out my
place i'm like
you put up a good fight i was like i'm
good i'm and they're like no no we're
excited for this and i'm like oh but
first we gotta thank our sponsor ftx us
now here's the thing with crypto having
declined in price it's more important
than ever to use an exchange that saves
you money on fees of which they do
they're trusted by millions of users who
buy sell track and trade both crypto and
nfts all in one place with fees that are
actually up to 85 percent lower than the
top competitors hey that's a pretty big
discount you know all the other
exchanges they tack on these hefty fees
on every single trade it is disgusting
but with ftx the fees are 85 less than
competitors the other great thing about
ftx us is that they allow for automatic
recurring buys that you could dollar
cost average into the markets on a
regular basis and it's incredibly easy
jack actually let me show you all you
got to do is type in what you want to
buy how much of it you want to buy how
often you want to buy it then you swipe
right and you're done they'll handle it
all for you without any additional work
on your end and you get free crypto in
every single trade you make over ten
dollars ftx is soon launching ftx stocks
and you're gonna be able to trade stocks
crypto and nfts all in one platform it's
going to be amazing so if you guys want
free crypto and you want to start
trading crypto and nfts with very low
fees today check out ftx with the link
down below in the description it also
helps support the podcast so we really
appreciate that too again the link is
down below in the description to get
started today and now with that said
let's get back to the podcast here's the
thing that you have a huge advantage so
i was reading on reddit and everyone who
was like a you know semi-pro or you know
amateur fighter was saying the first
fight like that is the most difficult
because you go in and you're not
prepared but doing it again you know
it's like okay i know i'm going to be
out of breath i know what it's going to
feel like with all the you know the
adrenaline going on i know what the
crowds get so you have an advantage that
nobody else would have because like
you've been through it before and you
also see just how hard you would need to
train yeah
yeah i didn't
it's true what they say until you're in
the ring you don't understand yeah
because like you train so much before
your fight
i train so much but then when you get in
it even sparring's not the same
you get a hit and you're like huh
you're punching me yeah you're punching
me and i think my issue was just i
didn't train cardio enough i couldn't
keep my hands up yeah do you have
anything else you want to say we have uh
three minutes two minutes i got a quick
question if we get asked if before um
i've noticed people that do twitch have
uniquely dedicated like fans and
i wanna know your take on it why do
youtubers there could be a youtube
channel with like five million
subscribers but their instagram could
have like 20 000 followers and then
their engagement could be like you know
40 likes or 100 likes a post but for
some reason it is unique within the
twitch community where those creators
they can have you know like a million
followers on on instagram but their
their twitch has you know i don't know
two three million followers how are the
conversions so good for fans on twitch i
think it's the fact that it's real time
it's talking like a youtube video i
personally prefer youtube because you
can sit there but when you're with
career you're seeing them do it live
there's no editing there's no cutting
like because i watched a lot twitch
people before i blew up and it just was
it was more engaging i can like type to
them they'll see my message i'll see
their reaction live
whether with youtube you see it after
and they might like the comment but it's
for me it was like oh my god i'm
not to be parasocial i'm seeing this
person like react to this thing and when
twitch blows the up and then you can
just
be like hey follow my answer right now
and then
you know you can put that in a youtube
video but then when chat responds and
they're like no thanks and it's like do
it do it like it's an easier way to
engage it's and twitch clips i mean you
know twitch has been
going and saying lately but now i think
youtube might be making the comeback
because they're gaming right they're
taking a lot of the biggest creators
yeah that's a lot and like tim the
tatman myth lilypichu
youtube if they get their
emotes and check like their bttv their
chat
i think they could outgrow twitch at
this point i agree they could they could
conquer twitch and maybe spotify for
podcasts
so that's why i think they have to head
though because there's so much
competition they're not going to compete
as well with tick tock so
what's left podcasts and uh twitch tick
tock is insane
it's too addicting it is but it's also
like the amount of opportunities it's
given like you know a little nas blew
off from that you have music creators
that grow
from
tick tock and tick tock creators too
though because you're not talking with
them one-on-one it doesn't feel like
you're having a relationship with them
but the the the relationship between
followers on tick tock and the tick tock
creator is also like twitch it's like
it's
it's so much more than just like a
youtube and a subscriber and then it's
easier to go overall because it's a
shorter thing and it goes up and
that's why i love like if anyone wants
to get into music that i think tick tock
right now is the best place to go you
put one song on there it's catchy people
will reuse it more people will hear it
and then it's so i even though tick tock
is going to cringe i think it's one of
the best platforms for smaller careers
scroll like twitch like i said i
streamed seven years
youtube i tried since i was a kid
tick-tock one viral thing can set you
off into
famousness yeah famousness cool is that
a word yeah it may as well be well thank
you so much i really appreciate it we
gotta go up to the uh the carrot thing
right now so thank you guys and we'll be
right back that was great thanks for
having me so now we're going to be
having on marina silicon valley girl who
by the way was one of the first people
that we've ever had on the podcast back
when jack was uh still in college yup
sounds weird yeah anyway we're gonna
have her on because lately she has been
going completely viral on tick tock she
has a huge youtube channel and we're
gonna be getting some updates on her in
terms of her business and uh what else
jack and her baby she had two babies she
did thank you so much for coming back on
because were one of our first guests
ever on the iced coffee hours oh was the
first one of one of them i think it was
number ten
maybe the episode number ten so you
would guess like number five or
something like that oh okay that's
pretty that's pretty cool those are the
really early days though before we did
like any crazy thumbnails or anything
like that like you were there 20. yeah
yeah the kitchen did it was a dining
room table that's crazy so a lot has
changed you've been deciding whether to
um
leave college yeah that was the time
oh my gosh
wow it's nuts we were still doing this
before he dropped out i remember that
used to be the talk it used to be
college then it went on like girlfriend
stuff and now it's like outsourcing that
is so funny
all right yeah so do you regret not
finishing college uh yeah man i wish i
wish i quit all this work i was actually
advocating for finishing were you really
yeah because i'm pro-education let's
talk about that a little bit more why
are you pro-education first of all you
run an education business right can you
explain to us what exactly this
education business is so it initially
started as a study abroad booking
platform so you could book a trip to
spain to learn spanish or trip to the us
to learn english but during covet we
lost 90 percent of our revenue so we had
to pivot and we pivoted to to an online
learning platform so we basically work
with creators in educational space and
they create product for us and we
distribute it
how many languages do you speak
a russian english german and a little
italian fluently well i studied
mathematics in german but it was in 2010
when i study in germany so i think i
won't be able to use it like on a daily
basis now but english and russia russian
is my native and english why did you
decide to learn so many languages
well when you don't speak english
english is the number one language you
have to learn because it opens all the
doors i wouldn't be here
if i didn't learn english um german i
was like my dream was always to study
abroad and going to the us or uk you
can't really afford it as a russian
family and germany had free education
and i was like let's learn german
and i really fell in love with the
country and like with the products that
germany creates for the world
um so this is why i learned german and
italian i just had italian friends and
they were sisters and they would always
chat to each other in italian and i was
fascinated by the way it sounded so i
decided to learn a little bit of that
you speak any other languages grammar i
took four years of spanish and one year
of latin how good are you both terrible
really yeah really i don't remember a
single thing really nothing
let's see
oh wow four years yeah four years holy
cow
i don't use it like
yeah i regret because i definitely i
think spanish would be such a fantastic
language to learn but
would you do videos in spanish though no
uh i i think it's good to understand and
be able to speak but i don't know when i
was in high school i had very very
narrow focused and it was either i'm
playing the drums or i'm working and if
it wasn't either of those two i had no
interest in it so i didn't pay attention
got it yeah i was the k you know what i
used to do there was some sort of like
he she they them like those sort of uh
differentiations and i'd write them i
think on my on my hand before going in
class so i could if i would take it yeah
cheat
yeah you would cheat that was the only
way i think i passed did you ever get in
trouble for cheating um
i think once i got caught with having
notes
and the teacher took the notes and told
me that if i got caught again
that uh you know he would flunk me from
that so i'm guessing you continued
cheating i just didn't get caught okay
he said if i got caught again but didn't
say that i couldn't continue i don't i i
don't remember what i have a feeling
that you would be like an exemplary
student
for some reason straight you were
straight a's where'd you go to college
st petersburg saint petersburg and then
from there and dress in university in
germany for like a semester but then i
got accepted to johns hopkins a
full-ride scholarship for their master's
program and university of florida mba
full-ride scholarship but then we could
also we accepted investment from 500
startups and we decided that i would
focus on the business
instead of doing my mba how has uh your
income shifted over these last two years
from going in person to online
how have you evolved as well with the
creative process in gross revenues we
lost a lot but then we're making more on
selling online products because if
you're selling an offline product you
have partners as well
um but we're still getting to
pre-pandemic revenues
really yeah
why do you think that is because i would
feel like for an online business that
there would be a lot of demand for
people who have the time let's just say
during the pandemic to learn another
language yeah i think it's the average
check the average check before was like
two to three thousand dollars and we
have
thousands of people traveling we were
like number one for a lot of schools all
over the world and now like we have the
same audience but the average check is
like 150 dollars so it's different got
it now i have to say that the one thing
you have been doing really well is the
what i spend or a day in the life
a mom in san francisco let's just say
those videos are so much fun to watch
and i keep the short videos yeah i keep
getting them recommended like you go to
the grocery store like putting items in
your basket and comparing the cost it's
crazy how they're blowing up like i'm
even not ready for that right now when
you're posting a video i'm used to like
100k views but if you get like two
million views overnight and like all the
different people
who watch your videos because i'm
targeting you know young entrepreneurs
or people who would want to start a
business and now like millions of people
are watching them so it's it's new it's
interesting how did you come up with
that idea i started researching the
algorithm on tiktok and somebody told me
that you actually need to post yourself
so i had my assistant in ukraine who was
helping me with posting so we saw most
of the audience coming from asia and
like eastern europe and then thought
what if i post with my american sim card
what would change and so because it was
me creating content i was like let's
create something you know that i wanted
to create so i created a video about
having a baby in california and how much
it cost and i just posted it with my sim
card and it blew up like in a day or
maybe like in a week i think it was
seven million views and i got featured
in mashable buzzfeed and i was like oh
my god so it was the sim card and this
new format that i thought i would do so
yeah crazy wow how are you continuing
that momentum
so you see like
when we're talking about those short
videos the price is the shock factor and
i think this is why people are watching
till the very end and then they hear the
price like i went to this dentist and
they gave me an estimate to like fix my
teeth and was like two thousand dollars
and people like what's going on here
like i could continue doing that and
like going to ear one and like showing
how much it costs that should be
fantastic so okay i did uh yeah i'm a
little ignorant i guess on this this
these haven't showed up in my feed the
exact so you go to the pc you
recommended jack
you go to these places you're pulling a
bunch of different items off the shelf
and at the end you show the total cost
of it all yeah and it's just blowing up
and people freaking out as well
as a tick tock it was a
short ticket um well i guess short on
take that it's like 60 seconds on tick
tock yeah the the big one though i
remember seeing the the cost of having a
baby how much was that
two 2 300 something like that after
insurance of going to the hospital and
like giving birth yeah and like giving
birth like doctors were not even there
when i had my baby because i had her so
fast they walked in i was already with
the baby
who delivered it uh so that there was
just a lady who was watching me and she
was like i was like the baby's coming
she's like okay
how painful is that
um well the first time was more painful
but the second time was like your body
just get you gets used to it is it the
was the first time
i'm curious to actually okay so was the
first time that you gave birth was that
the most painful thing you've ever
experienced because i've heard no on
many accounts
giving birth is like the most painful
thing
no i think like no because i i had a
couple of surgeries and like recovering
after surgeries is a lot more painful
because i think this is a natural
process and your body releases so many
hormones i know it's the first time
you're talking about
having run on this podcast but like your
body releases hormones where we were
meant to have babies you know just doing
our daily stuff like we would hide for
several hours have the baby and then go
back to our lives
um and because you're you know
i've never tried drugs but yeah
you didn't you weren't i never tried i
never tried yeah and when you're having
a baby you're like you love everyone i
saw babies and i started crying because
i was like i'm gonna have another baby
right now so it's just the hormones it's
just crazy you you're in the outer space
so you didn't have any sort of epidural
alert no and that wasn't as painful as
this so what was the surgery that you
had that was that painful i had um what
is it called so they had to cut out
something from my stomach but they had
three holes and then i couldn't walk
after it for days so that was really
painful um but having a baby was natural
so
yeah you don't hear of many births
without uh oh yeah hey man you know i
was born without any pain medications
you were born
what
yeah so my mom when she had uh
uh my half-sister
she
i don't know she she had the epidural or
whatever was given
but because i was going to be
her last um
that she wanted to have a natural
experience
and so i've heard it's it's better
because apparently i think the epidural
does something to the the child when it
comes out like there's some after
effects that maybe they come out that
makes sense numb or something i think
there's something like that i'm not an
expert by any means i'm probably
butchering that really bad but no yeah i
wanted this natural experience so i
worked with doulas for helping me
concentrate and demo was part of my
husband he was helping me a lot so it
was truly magical and how has having a
child like affected has it affected your
business at all like your business
philosophy or philosophies in life in
general are they good for business
i don't think unless you're trying to
build like a family vlog
but in general
triple views
yeah it's hard to focus because
sometimes you have a plan like i'm gonna
film every day of the week and then your
child gets sick and that's it
your plans are
you you stay with your kid so yeah it's
different now i can't really plan ahead
would you ever consider getting a nanny
i haven't we haven't
you haven't eaten we haven't nannies the
problem is like the kid needs you as a
parent yeah the nanny helps with daily
things but also when the kid is sick
it's you
uh who they need got it what was the
most unexpected thing for you being a
parent hmm
interesting how dependent we're going to
be on the nanny right we won't really be
able to travel like for example went to
europe
uh a year ago when the kids were really
small we wouldn't be able to do it
without nanny
what do they do exactly
yeah it's such a help
sometimes she sleeps with them so i can
get the full night rest because when you
have a small kid they would wake up
several times a night and you you just
don't get enough sleep that's number one
thing i'd say
got it yeah i think graham wants to have
a child at some point you know at some
point trying to
get a feel it out yeah i'm not ready by
any means like i could go probably
another ten years and then feel like all
right maybe maybe now i don't it's a big
commitment
i know it's at some point but i feel
like right now i'd be too selfish like i
want to be too focused on this anything
that takes time away
i wouldn't uh be as receptive i don't
think i'd be a good parent right now one
thing alex hormozy said when we add him
on our podcast is that
it would be hard for him to have a child
and be okay with his child not being the
exact person he wants him to be oh he
wants the child to be what do you think
about that being a parent yourself but
you can't control that right but he says
he would just have a hard time with that
accepting that accepting that yeah and
gate and he adds that to the the risk of
having a child like what if i don't like
my childhood oh you would not love your
child regardless of course what if they
don't like you
maybe that's how they phrased no this is
not how we built the kids are built to
love their parents and do anything that
their parents do but let's say he has an
expectation of his child in his child's
i don't want to do that i'm doing my
thing
uh and it happens to be crime or maybe
it's you know drugs we're talking about
older kids older kids yeah i'm talking
like you know 20s 30s they just grow
you know in a different direction that's
not as intended it's maybe not the best
for
the society yeah i think my approach to
this i want them to be happy and then
want them to be good citizens
so
i have 18 years to teach them all i can
and then after that it's really up to
them
so you can change their personality
after 18 you think people are pretty
certain yeah that's interesting
yeah i think for me my biggest thing
would be like if they don't have that
drive or work ethic
then i would feel like but no this is
something you can teach them this is
something you can totally teach them
because they wouldn't be too
i don't know like i'm not very different
from my parents because you just live in
this world and this is how you see the
world and the kids they just learn from
you yeah that's it but here's the thing
though like what if i don't do a good
job at teaching what if they see like oh
you know dad's always working i don't
want to work it's something like that
like maybe they want to like do the
positive way but it's a you can look at
it in a positive way like my debt is
always working that's amazing like if
you're mean to your children or you
don't like treat them well then i think
whatever you do they're probably going
to go against but i think if you like
shower your kid with love and support
obviously don't spoil them you know but
you live your own good life and you show
them love and you do your own thing
they'll look at you just like most
people would and be like that's a pretty
remarkable person i want to be just like
them yeah that's true so
i agree with that so on the the whole
business side of things how are your
businesses broken down currently what
businesses are you running
so my husband took over most of the
operations of linguatrip because it's
really hard when other people cannot
rely on you like sometimes the team
needs
a manager and i'm with a kid so we
decided that he's taking over all the
operations at linguatrip
uh i'm doing my channels i'm doing my
courses i'm doing brand deals
and then investing
so those are the two things that you
have going on it's the the language
course thing you have your own courses
like how to be a youtuber and stuff
right yes i remember those and then the
child and everything yeah that's
interesting two kids and how many hours
are you working then
four to five a day that's the maximum i
can do
but that's on top of taking care of of
course yeah yeah no like working is four
to five hours yeah and the rest is like
kids and
home
it's hard to relate because it's like we
don't have those experiences so like
we're trying to learn
but it's hard to be like oh yeah how
many hours do you work uh
it depends on the day usually
eight to twelve
a day i'd say but it depends on the day
like fridays i could take a little
earlier because you have a whole weekend
uh nothing happens in the market so i'd
say you work close to like 60 hours a
week 50 to 60. uh yeah
yeah probably that's fine but it's great
yeah but it depends
because sometimes i could get like five
hours of the work but it's so
concentrated and you're just like in the
zone and other days it'll be like 14
hours but my brain's scattered i don't
get quality work done it takes me so
much longer
and you're you've experimented with tick
tock right because i've seen your tech
talks oh kind of mm-hmm kind of kind of
this is a detox coffee hour yeah which
have been doing the iced coffee has been
doing really well for us oh no actually
the tick tock the tick tock account yeah
it's been doing really well uh for my
own personal we've had uh our guy just
clipping up little bits and pieces and
posting them i gotta do more on tick
tock though yeah i think realistic he
was here today yeah i saw him you should
talk to him and just put him on the
actual like a salary or something like
that hey i expect one per day because
i know i know i got to do that you
should try creating platform specific
content like tick tock specifically i
have the time
so true i haven't ever always has the
time man i am burnt out you don't have
the energy i don't but you have the time
something
something will have to
be pushed off something i'm at a point
now where i feel so good we're just
saying no
and like even of what i have right now i
just
like deep down which i think i might do
is just say no to like
just cancel the things i have going on
right now interesting yeah i and
everything i've i've cancelled i felt so
good afterwards like i felt so good
about the vlog i felt so good about just
everything else uh millennial money like
just not doing it it this
weight has been lifted off my shoulder i
feel so much better
and the more i say no to things the
better i feel the happier i am
zero oh my gosh now you could you
couldn't pay me to want to take that
back on i just i don't want to do it
anymore so so yeah for tick-tock content
it would take my time away from
something else uh even now selling i
sold one rental property that just
closed and now i'm like it's it's so
nice just not to think about it just a
mental i i could go off the deep end
here and just like sell everything i'm
not going to do that but it's just
the simplicity of just buying an index
fund i've loved it and i don't want to
deal with the properties anymore it's
like oh i have to pay property taxes and
remember like you know i had insurance
lap on a property that was so stupid and
it was just because i didn't have the
time i they sent me an email i didn't
see it
and uh insurance laughed for like three
months like what if something happened
in those three months and now i'm not
insured because i'm too busy to look at
an email and the property manager
isn't aware of that so
interesting so in five years ideally you
would just do one video a week and
that's it uh i don't know i because
sometimes i love the three videos a week
and i love the current schedule i think
if i could just
i think at the end of it i just need to
focus on the three things which is main
channel second channel iced coffee hour
and that's it i don't think i have any
capacity anymore for anything else other
than those
i think i just do those really well
that's my strength interesting because
yeah because i hear too many things
honestly and i've been thinking like you
know even listening to all these pitches
today i've been taking so much advice
from other people and just like oh yeah
they're right like you know
not saying this is wrong for you jack
but like the outsourcing or taking on
new projects and oh you should be doing
this and you know your audience is
perfect to you know collaborate with
these ideas and like
i think i think they're the wrong
choices for me mm-hmm and at the end
like i don't feel as excited as they
should be what's your answer
sorry uh it took over yeah no i think
it's fine uh i'm just just
enjoying what i do and i think at the
end of the like i enjoy
making
videos and like that's what i have the
most fun doing everything else at this
point but like if you could imagine an
event where you go as a very special
guest like oscars or nobel prize or
whatever like what would this event be
dr phil
joe wait me going on an event yeah yeah
like i'm getting an award or i don't
want an award i don't want
like a party where everybody graham
hates partying i don't go i'm i'm not
that social i don't know like a perfect
event for me would be like
six people all you could eat sushi
that would be the perfect event for me
who are those six people oh gosh uh well
jack obviously
no i just think honestly with the team
it's like you know me macy jack alex uh
kelsey and then jack's future girlfriend
six of us right there andrew could come
along andrew come on until you get a
girlfriend and then andrew you know
tested it he's my interim goal that's
that's great that you're like you're all
set now yeah so he's got everything he
wants you know what i'm dealing with the
team i gotta say so i i'm always pushing
to outsource i'm always pushing like try
this new thing try growing and stuff
like that but at the end of the day
knowing who you are and with your logic
i think
what you just said was extremely
reasonable and i agree i think i think
yeah look man if you're at the point of
just not having the energy i sympathize
and sympathize with that and i get where
you're coming from as long as you can
maintain what you're doing and you can
maintain it well
it's totally fine that's what i think
everything else has been stressing me
out lately and i just don't want the
stress anymore i just
i don't want to deal with it i just you
know i want to look at my emails and not
have to deal with it you know i just
want to focus
making videos
you know great so i think that's i've
learned that i think today was a good
revelation for me that's good man yeah i
think so that's great what about you
marina do you feel like you still have
all this energy to continue
pushing these new things and trying out
new businesses and scaling what you have
right now i think so you think so yeah i
just got excited like all the all the
things happening with short videos
like my choice right now is do i push it
and just do more or do i stop there
because like
the attention i'm getting i'm not ready
for it right now like millions of using
like as i was saying kids staring at me
in the streets and like not necessarily
getting the feedback i was expecting
when i was like showing the tesla and
all of the comments are about me showing
off with the tesla
oh i remember
okay so did you see this video jack okay
it's kind of funny
i'm going to speak candidly here no i
took the tesla to the car wash but
instead of calling it a car i took the
car the tesla
but this is what i'm used to like i said
yeah i know i i did the same thing i'm
like we're going to take the tesla
instead of we're going to take my car
gonna take the test that's interesting
yeah but everyone in the comments was
like i didn't know she had a tesla
tell me again that she had a tesla
people were like what car does she drive
again because
people do that with tesla yeah like
tesla specifically i did with everything
like i name things i give them a name
and like them the the most basic thing
you can name them is the the brand yeah
that's true no but i got my watch
do you say why does it apple i say apple
watch yeah and i think with tesla
specifically they do it nobody says like
i'm going to take my uh toyota
my nissan but they don't know my ford i
say my ford all the time
yeah
you should remake that but with ford
see what the reaction is they drive my
ford my celica my 87 seller
everyone's gonna think it's sponsored
[Laughter]
explore
xlt to make light of situations like
that kind of leaning into the joke you
know what i mean leaning in the joke but
it happens every time i deliver a
message but people see something
completely different
like because they go viral like if i get
300 like when i get 300 000 views i'm
like the feedback is perfect when i get
2 million views 11 million is 30 million
views this is when things go wild
i don't know like i'm excited about all
the views like this is cool i can
actually make this the stuff videos but
at the same time do i want people to see
me as a dumb girl who says tesla versus
car i know because they think it's dumb
i just think it's engagement
it's engaging i know but then i'm
thinking like if i sorry if i want to
work with you know this particular brand
like if they come to the comment section
would they want to work with me yes i
think so i think if you got canceled
you're not getting canceled people no no
none of you i don't think it matters at
all like the chris kris jenner she made
the
master class
and i i watched the master class i was
like okay she
okay it's a good product but what do
people say because kardashian said so i
went on read it people were looking on
this product and they were like i will
cancel my master class membership
because you did this i was like do i
want to be
like not exactly kardashians but don't
want to be this controversial person
that does something
and then the company is also getting
it depends how safe you want to play it
i think
there's a high risk high reward i think
the risk is pretty limited because
you're not saying it like saying my
tesla and people are poking fun at that
i i think it's very mild yeah i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
it's the nature of tick tock comments
right
our youtube shorts comments how it is i
think any brand would look at that and
say wow 20 million views that's
incredible
i don't think they're going through
reading the comments
i'd be surprised
i think it's worth it
because the thing is like when you're
talking to 20 million people like
that little minuscule percent is going
to be the most vocal about it every time
i have something
do better than average you get those
comments and the haters are way louder
oh yeah people that support you yeah
half the time i think they're joking
though it's after i think it's just like
you know exaggerating behind a computer
because it's funny and then if they
start getting up votes then it's like i
got all the attention and then if the
creator responds like wow i got their
attention
half the time i think it's just that
yeah yeah i don't think it's that
serious but you've got a knack for this
like you're on to something and we don't
know how long the algorithm is going to
work that's true that's absolutely true
this is what i'm like maybe we have six
months maybe like i would take your shot
because with this audience that you
could grow could be faster than like
taking 10 years somewhere else and you
could do it in six months
i think that the risk is low yeah just
just managing how people see because i
don't want to be seen as like this girl
who shows off in silicon valley this is
not the brand i'm trying to build here
like i try to convey one message and
people see another message
maybe have a review system for like have
it filtered through like five people and
then if they all like it like i watched
your video and i didn't think a single
thing about the tesla until i went to
the comments yeah
but you know what it's funny yeah that's
it but the comments
make made me watch it again uh so if
anything the comments could be it's like
this loop where it's like watch the
video go to comments watch the video
again to see if the comments were right
yeah
that could that could work too yeah it's
interesting yeah like the latest video
about the flying like the flying
experience when we had to wait etc but
everything everyone was focused on like
a broader neck on the airplane but this
is what russians do would bring eggs
cucumbers and uh ham to feed the babies
no on the plane on the plate
this is what we do and people like
freaking out
yeah but you know what but i think some
of it just i want to say the culture
differences
make it watchable and engaging that yeah
and the fact that you get so many
comments i just that's not something
that people get upset about at least
like i think that's fine yeah i think
something something to work on my with
myself as well because i think i want to
control everything and also the way
people see me and when i can't control
it i'm freaking out and that's my
problem i get you 100
like any time i see a hate comment it
makes my day so like okay this is gonna
get a lot of people to write hate
comments but it it doesn't make me feel
good right but i can see a bunch of
really nice compliments and i would say
like
the feeling that i get is so much less
than like you know what i mean that i
hate a comment for somebody
way more than you know nice comments put
you up yeah yeah i would say it's almost
100 to 1. like you have to get 100 good
comments to outweigh one bad comment
yeah i agree on that terrible but i
think that like that's something we can
all work on as creators is recognizing
like people watch you for a reason it
means they probably appreciate what you
have to say for the most part i agree
with you and also i'm a firm believer
it's like you get a pool of uh you know
100 of your people watch your video uh
let's say 99 enjoy it one percent
dislike it three percent of your
comments are going to be negative
because if you have a negative emotion
towards the video you're probably more
likely to comment than you know positive
that's true well thank you so much i
really appreciate it yeah what an
interesting episode i know yeah let me
know the next time i get right into your
recommended section let me know
i'm actually before reading the comments
okay i will do okay all right well thank
you so much for coming out thank you
it's good to see you guys so up next we
have nate o'brien coming on this is
going to be a really unique episode
because graham is actually going to be
busy for this one he has to judge this
event people are going to be pitching
him their startup ideas something like
that and uh it's just gonna be nate and
i so this is a one-on-one it's very
short 15 minutes you guys are gonna love
this one we get really personal tune in
hey guys thanks so much for tuning in i
have nate o'brien here today you may
notice graham steven he's gone he's not
present it's just nate and i we're going
to have a little low-key chat about some
business some cool stuff you're doing
because you're doing a lot of cool stuff
i don't know how much how much you
comfortable talking about nate uh we can
talk about a lot of business stuff yeah
okay because you're doing two things i
mean you've been on this podcast a
couple of times before we discussed your
like reclusive slash minimalistic life
that you're doing where you're like
going into like the rockies and like
living in a van yeah and at the same
time you're running like multiple
six-figure businesses online
and we can go into a little bit of both
of those sure yeah they are two total
like weird things like you wouldn't
think that they match up and they you
feel like they wouldn't align but uh
they do you're not a very flashy person
for like being so young making you know
some pretty good change yeah i don't
like the flash i don't like drawing
attention to myself um and i yeah i
never really set out to be like an
influencer or like to get attention it
was just sort of
an opportunity and so you know and
you've never been flashy or never wanted
to be no i don't want people looking at
me i'm trying to stay discreet you know
would you consider yourself kind of like
an introvert oh big time big introvert
i've gotten a lot better at speaking to
people just i forced myself to learn it
and
but my social battery dies very quickly
so i just spent five days in new york
with tons of meetings and now i'm just
like
and it's always been that way yeah yeah
yeah no actually before it was even bad
i wouldn't even go to social events
because i couldn't handle them why is it
like anxiety or do you think it's your
tolerance is low no just like i wasn't
good at holding conversations didn't
know how to
communicate with people i had to teach
myself how to do that i'm wondering if
since you spent assuming like that you
did this you spent time away from like
social events and parties and that kind
of lifestyle you were left to your own
devices and that gave you a lot of time
and opportunity to research like
different business strategies and stuff
like that yeah definitely especially
growing up because like i didn't have a
lot of friends and so
when everybody would go hang out or go
to the movies on the weekends in like
middle school i would just go
home into my room and just
like focus on like building things
and i'm always curious i asked this
question to a lot of people that come on
this podcast but i'm always curious like
what is it in you that is that innate
desire that i'm assuming you've always
had to be exceptional in something like
a lot of people i'm guessing live their
life and they just think you know like
i'm happy making ends meet doing my
thing you know settling down whatever
but it seems like a lot of people we
have on they just have this innate
desire do you know if it's like your
family instilling values on you or if
it's like just something your people are
born with um you know for me it was it
was actually because uh from a for
business thing it was because i wanted a
lot of freedom with with my time right
so like that's why i started all the
business ventures because you know i
didn't want to get a job i didn't want
to have to go to school and everything
so i was like let me just make some
money so i can just do whatever i want
whenever i want you could be tuesday and
i can just be you know sitting in a lawn
chair somewhere in the middle of the day
um
but yeah i mean my family didn't really
pressure me on anything so there wasn't
any like
big pressures like you need to go to
college you need to get a good job it
was just kind of hey do whatever you
want you know if you want to mow lawns
that's cool if you want to be a you know
a doctor that's cool too um but it was
very chill so i i don't know where that
came from i think it was just i love
learning i love uh really challenging
myself and i think you need growth
always um and so
if you know there's that saying like if
you're not growing you're dying right so
like just always moving forward in some
way just kind of keeps me happy and
everything in check yeah and what about
comparing yourself to other people
because
i do my best not to do it because it's
just i think it's just objective well
not objectively because you can use it
to your advantage but a lot of the times
it results in some pretty bad uh you
feel poorly right and i compare myself
believe it or not to you a lot
because we're the exact you're 23 right
yeah we're the exact same age right but
you get to live in the rockies and you
like have this cool van life but at the
same time you're making like crazy money
you get to travel a bunch you're like
nomadic
like that is like the ideal life in my
opinion do you find yourself comparing
yourself to other people oh the grass is
always greener on the other side i mean
um i remember actually you had you uh
and graham had kevin on the iced coffee
hour at one point and you actually like
i came up in the conversation and you
were talking about how you know you guys
would like to be me where you can just
kind of travel and stuff and then i was
watching and thinking i would love to be
graham where i could actually get out so
much more work or kevin where i can get
out you know seven videos a day so the
grass is always greener on the other
side yeah that's really interesting that
you that you want to be more productive
i mean honestly i'm pretty content where
i am um i mean i always have that like
work smarter before you work harder
mentality and it's like um also just you
know i'm i'm okay with not working 100
hours a week but i do wish i had that
capability of doing that is there ever a
time in your life do you think where
you'll just be like i have enough i i'm
making good money i've been making good
money for a long time i can stop on my
businesses and go travel i think that
would get depressing if i if you stopped
everything entirely i think right now
what i'm doing
is exactly what i wanted to do that's
like my dream of like
being able to travel and also growing
stuff on the side so like you don't need
to have a full sprint um
and sacrifice 30 years of my life in
order to still accomplish something
that's kind of so yeah i think i can do
both maybe i'm not going to be you know
a billionaire but um still i think i can
accomplish both at the same time have
fun while also growing businesses that's
interesting and onto your actual
businesses that you're running at the
moment it's interesting to me because
you have so many different businesses
and every time you come on here you're
always kind of like a little secretive
about what exactly is going on and i was
wondering if we maybe we could talk
about some of those businesses that
you're running how you built them up how
successful are they really
and uh yeah oh yeah i mean you know just
pay some bills um you have like some
youtube channels um and like you know
personal finance stuff and um yeah a
couple channels and uh
yeah they pay bills so you have your
main channel you have nato brian yeah
and
how much is that making are you are you
comfortable saying numbers are would you
rather i mean um yeah i probably don't
want to go into specific numbers but
it's it's like it's not making as much
as it did last year because i make one
video a month on it now um i feel bad
letting it totally die you know because
i feel like i have to like give people
something and also you know i could do
some decent-sized brand deals so i feel
bad like letting it go right but it
doesn't excite you that much no it
doesn't excite me that much because i i
think i've said everything i need to say
but why can't you just reorient the
reorient the type of content you're
putting out to stuff that you're you
know interested in because i just don't
really want to talk to a camera you know
there's there's other things that i'd
rather work on that that we are working
on so
okay so you're saying stuff where you're
behind the camera running some sort of
business or yeah yeah that stuff is good
as well like running channels without
being on them is is also great um but
even just beyond that sort of like the
stuff that i'm working on with sebby
with some of the venture stuff is is
more exciting let's talk about that for
a second because i know i actually only
became aware of this other business that
you're doing with sebby i don't know how
long maybe like three maybe like it was
a month and a half ago or something you
guys all came to vegas and we all went
like
gambling i guess like we don't play
poker oh man that was rough it was rough
i i was so scared playing poker in vegas
it was like one of the first time i've
played two so i didn't really know what
was going on but you know we're trying
to crack jokes and stuff and everybody's
so serious at the poker table in vegas
it's just yeah yeah that was a tough
experience right there but i remember
sitting at the poker table and you're
talking about like some new business
venture with sebby and i was completely
caught off guard by it maybe i'm just
out of touch but what exactly is this
business that you're doing with ask
debbie we've had him on the podcast
before uh
yeah he's a really really smart guy yeah
sebby's great guy um genius um and so uh
if you remember graham invested into
yada right which is which is that uh
banking app and you know they do a lot
of really cool things um but so graham
invested in that through one of sebby's
syndicates so sebby
going back on some of his history and
the reason why we partnered together is
because he had a company he was a
co-founder of a company that uh got
acquired by a firm back in i think 2015
and then he actually became a youtuber
and that's sort of how we all connected
with him um but at some point around
2020 he started running syndicates um
and he lives in sf so he's very tied in
with the venture world and uh like like
that very early stage uh preceding and
seed companies um and so he's doing
those syndicates and then eventually
we kind of combined forces and said hey
let's launch a formal uh venture fund
and uh so so we just launched uh uh like
back in in may so it's been pretty
recent um and just kind of focusing on
like hey look we're creators uh creators
having equity in companies and we can
help those companies uh grow and that's
kind of the main thesis there so explain
it what's that thing they say and right
like explain like i'm five or whatever
okay
give it to me like that right like say i
don't even know what uh all right
syndicate is so let's take it actually
from from the startups perspective right
okay wait so you don't know what kit is
so basically a syndicate is when you
just get a group of people together and
that creates like a vehicle that then
invests into a company okay right so
sebby went he went to graham he went to
myself he went to a handful of other
finance influencers he said hey there's
this really cool company it's super
early
the the raising on their seed round at a
certain valuation
i think we should get all these craters
together and invest into this company
and get some equity in them because look
like you know graham like
say for example weeble right how much
equity has been driven by graham for
weeble over the past five years is
probably an insane amount and like he
got paid you know a lot of cash but if
you had equity if there's a potentially
it'd be worth even more or like when i
started promoting robinhood in 2016 i
don't know what the valuation was
probably 100 million or something you
know and then they at one point they're
worth over 10 billion um so instead of
getting five dollars in cash having some
equity that would have been really
incredible
yeah so you're saying
you get a bunch of people together and
when you're basically shouting out these
companies are doing affiliates and stuff
like that driving traffic instead of
being paid cash people are being paid
equity in these companies essentially or
so there's different ways to do it you
can be paid in equity which is through
one of seve's companies called subscribe
which you should just have on again to
talk about it because it's really
interesting um or just investing into it
but imagine
as an influencer if every company that
you're promoting and is sponsoring your
video you have you own a piece of that
company like how incredi like really
important that could be um and that's
what the big people do you know that's
what like logan paul does with a lot of
his stuff or the kardashians right um i
mean just just look at the stuff that
they're talking about right logan paul's
not doing one-off videos with um like
some random brand most of the stuff that
he's promoting today or mr beast for
example he does some one-off stuff but a
lot of the stuff like feastables with
his willy wonkas yeah yeah he has
invested in his own aside from exactly
so so creators shouldn't just be
focusing on cash they should like it's
also nice to have cash plus
some interest in that because really the
real money in most of business is built
in equity appreciation that's
interesting and it also makes sense that
the businesses would prefer this as well
because then also they get to like first
of all you get like to add the the
creator whoever's you know shouting you
out as your list of you know like people
that own or whatever yeah
and also you know it's probably a little
cheaper if you're a startup and you're
you know
and then also we can really help on on
uh helping the companies understand hey
look you're overpaying influencers right
because i'm sure you guys see that as
well where there's some uh startups who
will raise some money and they just
don't know what's the going rate for
influencers and so that's what we're
kind of there to help them as investors
into their company we have the
connections right so we know a lot of
influencers we can connect them with
them for potential brand deals and also
tell them look you're getting screwed
you're paying too much for new users or
whatever it might be so yeah we just
feel like it's a great uh relationship
so that's that right there you have that
you have your main channel and then what
else do you have going on
um i mean those are really the two main
things um and then um
yeah and then just also a lot of
networking which is kind of a weird
thing you can't really i've never found
a ton of value in networking but i know
you go to all these conferences you go
to all these events and meet up with a
bunch of other like companies and
creators what value do you find in that
um it's a couple things so going back to
what i said earlier i love learning and
so when i can just meet people and they
have a new business like we were just
talking to john right and he was telling
us about his his new company that he
launched lucy um which i'm assuming i
can talk about on here but yeah yeah um
and yeah it's just so interesting and
like i i would love to get on a call
with him and talk for three hours about
the company just learn about it
and that might almost be a downside in
the hopes of investing no no no just
because i'm genuinely interested and
this might be one of my sort of like
kryptonites like my uh things that uh is
almost bad where i'm too interested in
things uh and in everything that
sometimes i feel like i waste my time
like for example um i don't make a ton
of videos on youtube on my channel
because i'm going to be honest some of
my time is just spent you know i'll
spend six hours like researching a
publicly traded company to try to make a
trade when maybe i should just be making
videos but i just love learning and i'm
just always intrigued by things that's
really interesting and do you ever spend
time like wasting it away like on tick
tock or just like scrolling on youtube
shorts or something like that like
i do that um yeah i mean i'm sure i do
uh i would say the way that i waste time
is probably a little bit different than
other people so i i don't consume really
short form content i try to stay away
from it just because i can't yeah like
get away like it's so hard to get out of
tick tock if once you enter into it
you'll be on it for two hours so i mean
i waste time like i'll drive
for 15 hours on the road somewhere and
just um you know so that's kind of a
waste i'm telling you i mean you're
driving you're like listening to some
crazy people yeah yeah you're like
thinking of your next multi-million
dollar business okay yes yes but um okay
yeah that's true but i i love just
learning i love consuming as much as
possible
okay so that's all of the businesses
that you have going on basically for the
most part right yeah pretty much i mean
i have a couple like
uh channels with my brother that also
you know just kind of help like
diversify a little bit but other than
that yeah that's pretty much it
and one thing i kind of wanted to make
apparent because
i remember before i was like in the
youtube scene and i would
i would watch content similar to this i
would see like people that were you know
near my age and i see them talking and
they're all like businessy or whatever
and i'm like gosh like why am i not
doing that and i want to make it clear
to people i've always wanted to say this
on the podcast but now i guess it's the
perfect time it's like nate and i when
we're not talking on the podcast it's
not always about like you know these
crazy business plans that we have like
we all like we just talk you know we
joke around and talk about random stuff
too oh totally i always just wanted to
say that because i feel like that
there's there's this idea that like
people like graham people like you
people like me like it's all business
all the time
that's not necessarily the case no yeah
we we do a lot outside of um business
you know yeah gotta have fun yeah so
graham
i mean you're still gone
i'm still just saying so graham's still
gone i mean he's here right now but
recording this after the fact uh but
right now i guess in the video he's like
recording still and we figured it'd be
fun if we brought on ask sebby and nate
o'brien is gonna be filling in for
graham he is my new co-host of this
podcast let's get on with the show with
ask sebby welcome back to the iced
coffee hour we have my co-host nate
o'brien uh graham's actually filming the
thing right now and we wanted sebion and
we couldn't have done it otherwise so
nate's my co-host yeah i've never
co-hosted before so but you wanted to
start a podcast so this is a good
opportunity to test out your skills yeah
so to be like interrogate him or
whatever yeah don't you have a nato
bryan show what happened to that ah it's
just been on the back burner forever
yeah all right well
well we have ask sebby we've had you on
the podcast before people loved the
episode okay we talked about how you're
an unemployed person making 10 million
or whatever i don't i don't remember
something
it was some click bait that graham came
up with and i was like all right sounds
good to me so we brought you back on uh
to talk about a lot of crazy stuff
that's going on with you and your
businesses and i know you've currently
partnered with nate on this new business
venture we kind of talked about it
briefly when i had nade on um i'm gonna
go ahead and pass it to you nate what do
you gotta say um yeah uh kind of like
see this is not a good host it's okay
man it's okay um what should i ask him
okay here i have a question for you um
i'm never starting a podcast i can't do
it i'm retired i got it man you got it
um
but uh yeah what
what was your reasoning for um
i have nothing i have nothing i believe
in you okay okay actually tell us about
the company that got acquired by a firm
because you're so stealthy about that
and i didn't even know that until last
year and nobody knows that because he's
so quiet about it
yeah so that was we're basically helping
people attending coding boot camps get
loans because
coding boot camps is one of those like
weird things where if you attend it
there's a very high likelihood that you
get a very high paying job so i think a
lot of people who are not in the new
yorks and the bay areas of the world or
even las now
you don't realize that tech jobs can pay
an absurd amount like a lot of people in
normal places view six figures as kind
of the dream and
oftentimes that's kind of the starting
point for a lot of
software engineering roles and we're
trying to help people
uh get into these programs because
they're otherwise expensive uh so
basically it was a lending platform for
that purpose okay so you were like tech
lead kind of in a way
um not really tech lead more so like
kind of a a firm or like a sofa like
getting a loan in order to attend the
program i think tech lead is selling you
his course
so for some reason
it's hard basically to give loans or to
go through the underwriting process
exactly
for people that aren't making money yet
exactly for people that go through this
coding bootcamp it's almost guaranteed
that as they get out they have a very
marketable skill they can get a high
paying job so you guys were providing
loans for people
pretending to attend those is it a
tuition loan or is it like a loan so
those are tuition loans uh but it wasn't
because these aren't like technically
like colleges or traditional ones
they're more like secondary programs so
the hard part was making sure that we
weren't financing bad programs so a lot
of these okay so it depends so some of
them are very good and that they're
focused on you getting hired and
actually getting a good job and they
have a good track record a lot of other
copycat ones were like okay you can
charge people twenty one thousand
dollars or seventeen thousand dollars to
teach them the bare basics and there's
no risk on their end so we need to make
sure that we weren't funding those oh so
it depends on actually the boot camp
that these people are going to yeah so
we were trying to go after like the
harvard and stanford's of those programs
to make sure that people had a higher
likelihood of getting employed
afterwards and also being able to repay
and these weren't loans that were backed
by the government no numbers are just
purely it was peer-to-peer lending how
are you
how are you uh kind of like evaluating
the sort of like the credit risk or like
the default risk and were you shipping
that risk off are you just like bringing
it all on so we were just a technology
platform so we were not taking on the
credit risk we were a platform
facilitating
everything um and then also
the risk it was more so looking at the
results of those coding bootcamps and
how they previously performed so some of
them like again if you don't have a
track record there uh not that good if
you're someone who
has a tendency of placing people at
these high-paying jobs then that's a
lower risk but the idea is that
uh you might be very smart you might be
underemployed right now let's say you're
working
like mcdonald's or something but like
you are actually smart but without that
actual education then you have a hard
it's a very hard path to get into that
traditional role and by going to this
program it can changeably
increase your income from thirty
thousand dollars to let's say eighty
thousand hundred thousand dollars but
you might not wanna pay that upfront or
you might not have the ability to get a
loan off it and who were the typical
lenders was it just like random people
that had good money or was it like
businesses or banks yeah a lot of the
lenders were not banks a lot of the
lenders were pretty much other tech
people who have
oftentimes seen the ability of tech to
like kind of change people's lives and
also some other people who are
arbitraging too because they were like
well i can make eight percent here and
it makes sense because the credit risk
feels relatively low and that was kind
of the rise of the prospers of the world
where you were there were a lot of like
peer-to-peer lending platforms taking
off and then that got acquired by a firm
yeah how much was the acquisition for uh
i can't say
but where did your role fall into place
in this
it was pretty much a bit of everything
so a lot of kind of marketing
partnerships
a bit of product
like as a founder you're not really
doing just one thing i think
a lot of people when they think of jobs
especially like traditional corporate
jobs you're like looking very much like
okay i do this anything beyond that i'm
not interested in i'm only hired for
this and that makes sense when you're an
employee but when you're like a founder
or when you're like working with graham
for example you're probably doing a bit
of everything right like it's not like
graham's hiring you to edit he's like
all right cool can you also send this
email can you take out the trash can you
pick up this package for me you taking
out the trash for granted no
no i've never i've never taken out
graham's trash but i have visited the
postal office for him yeah so the same
idea but um yeah that was a while ago
now that's like seven years ago now so
uh and then uh transitioned into youtube
so why did you pivot to youtube because
i feel like when someone exits a company
then i feel like they just go on to
their next startup and i feel like
youtube is sort of so i've never seen
that really so ironically youtube was
initially kind of i was debating turning
that into a nick startup so i pretty
much got very obsessed with credit cards
i kind of realized how much value you
could get from it because for me as
someone who grew up relatively like i
would say lower middle class income i
never thought i'd fly business class or
first class for that matter so seeing
how you can actually use points to do it
and i'm like oh wait like instead of
just turning those points into seven
hundred dollars in cash that can be a
business class flight that would
otherwise cost seven thousand dollars so
the fact that i can kind of see how the
other side lives
was very interesting to me and then i
kind of dove into that rabbit hole of
like oh crap like there's all these
cards you can actually kind of modify
your span you can also sign up for them
and just hit the intro bonus and do that
so initially uh first off i got very
addicted to it and then i was just
telling my friends about it that's kind
of how that whole thing happened where i
spent like 30 minutes like 45 minutes
talking to a friend about like the chase
sapphire reserve it's like hey you need
to get this card it makes so much sense
and then they were like alright cool and
the next time i saw them they're like
hey can you explain the card again i'm
like no
so i was like oh yeah i'm just gonna
make content it's like first at a
minimum it's going to be a friend who
watches it if they need to watch 10
times great but it's like just
explaining the idea that like this is a
no-brainer as long as they're not over
spending and worst case you can
downgrade this into a new manual v card
so that was kind of the starting point
and then
uh yeah i just started making more
content people were interested and then
i i was surprised that i was getting a
lot of smart comments too because i
associated youtube with like dumb comedy
for lack of a better example where like
the prank type stuff more than anything
uh so just to see like actual like
professionals and smart people coming
and say oh yes
i i did this trip i did this trip that
was pretty cool to me and then
initially that
that whole thing was because i was also
doing like a blog where i was trying to
make the next like nerd wallet
yeah so how many credit cards you have
because i know you have a lot i'm saving
that for a future video so i need to
dozens
at least potentially yes
many more than 30.
and now i know you're going into like a
lot of startup investing and stuff like
that can you tell us a little bit more
about
i remember last time we talked we talked
about the the business you just
discussed what has changed since the
last time we talked it was probably what
like 10 months ago
yeah so oh which business like the
startup investing business uh it was the
one that got acquired by a firm it was
the the loan the lending one yeah so
that was like eight years ago that was
like a while ago yeah we talked about
that in the first ever coffee our
episode yeah so i ended up starting
another company recently uh with mandy
my co-founder that's basically helping
content creators work with startups for
equity instead the idea being that a lot
of companies just can't pay what
creators are worth especially
because personal finance rates might be
more expensive than people realize
and then the other half of it is that we
have seen so many of these companies
grow from let's say a 50 million
valuation or 80 million to a two billion
a one billion valuation like a unicorn
so if you think about it like we're
actively helping these companies 10 20
50 x in value but often times when they
come to us in the early stage they kind
of do the opposite they're like we can't
pay that much because we're an early
stage company and we'll pay you less now
but maybe i'll pay you more in the
future and like you don't really want to
take that handshake agreement because
first off they might not necessarily pay
you more and secondly
maybe that maybe it just doesn't make
sense for them to do that so it's like
okay cool how do you like incentivize uh
creators to have that upside so that's
the equity component and then in
addition recently
uh ended up starting a rolling fund of
nato brian uh the idea being that we end
up seeing a lot of deals we were doing a
lot of angel investing anyways and by
having this fund it basically means that
we can help either uh high net worth
individuals
invest and get access to these deals
that they otherwise wouldn't or creators
who just don't have the time right
because creators even if they might be
interested in getting their hands dirty
they have so many different things
they're working on that
investing is this whole other thing that
maybe it's not worth the time yeah and
sitting in on meetings too like and like
i've never run syndicates but you've run
many of them that i've been in and um i
can imagine how sort of just much of a
headache it is to round up influencers
to get them on a call with a founder and
then have the influencer do some level
of due diligence and then you know so
it's it's uh definitely the fund made a
lot more sense
and what about the the public companies
like the
the bigger stock market how how when
that goes down and or when that's
struggling how does that affect the the
private companies and stuff that you
guys are more in tune with yeah i would
say that funding slows down but good
companies are still getting funded i
think the problem is that
a lot of private investors look at these
public companies as multiples so for
example if you were making a mattress
company right now you're like okay cool
who's the whale in the space casper if
casper's not doing well then your upside
is so minimal as well so that's kind of
the big risk there unless you have some
other like twist to it or like something
else going on so eight sleep is one
where even though they are a mattress
company they're more so technology
company because they have cooling they
do a lot of data stuff on the back end
they have like the sas play where they
charge you a monthly fee to get your
information and stuff uh so i think like
it just depends on how you position it
uh but i would say generally a bit of a
pullback yeah it it sort of trickled
down like it started with uh say
november when elon and bezos and some of
those big guys started selling a lot of
their public shares and then it sort of
trickled down from public to like the
late stage like you know like the series
c and series d and then eventually now
it's even affected like the seed and
precede where they're having to lower
their valuations as well overall i would
say it's a net good thing because it
means that the valuations have come down
to earth i'd say before that like in the
last
especially last year in particular a lot
of valuations were in like the absurd
range where it was like pre-products
idea pre-anything it's like 50 ml
yeah yeah pretty much how do these
companies even come up with their
valuation like do they just say oh i
think this company's worth this much and
then it's kind of like it establishes
its its own market and then people are
like oh i'm willing to contribute this
amount of money at this valuation or is
there actual like statistics or
data to back up each valuation so i
think some people will say that it's the
probability of you becoming a billion
dollar company and like how you want to
price that i'd say it's more so just
what people want to pay right like
if people if you're uh someone who's
last start up as well front and you've
done well you have a good track record
of like founding these billion dollar
companies and making people 10 to 20 x
back people happily invested a higher
valuation and then for someone who's
like fresh out of school then it's
probably going to be a lower evaluation
or if you don't have a track record so
just because a company is valued at a at
a high amount doesn't necessarily mean
you wouldn't say accurately represents
the chances of this company becoming a
billion dollar business no i think if
anything sometimes the higher the
valuation the harder it might be to even
be to hit the goal to keep raising money
so one of the things that startups i
think people get like confused with
especially if they watch a lot of shark
tank is the whole like focus on
necessarily cash flow they'll be like oh
like what's your margin on this what's
your cash flow it's like yes that's
important for certain things like d2c
where like if you're selling a can that
matters a lot but if you're doing
software oftentimes in the early stage
it's about acquisition and whether you
can like grab the market
and you can kind of figure out how to
like turn on more profit like
like levers afterwards to
make it so that you are more profitable
so like if you look at like most
companies early on like amazon's a good
example of this where like for a long
time they were like
other people's margin is their
opportunity because they wanted to keep
expanding and then that's kind of how
they got into their position but if you
look back into like the finance
uh like new shows uh like 20 years ago
talking about amazon everyone thought it
was a joke so it's it's a tough thing i
think what's the biggest factor you look
at on somebody let's say it's a kid
who's 18 years old and they have an idea
and they're trying to raise at a 25
million valuation uh what's like the
biggest thing you look at to say okay
this is this is the person that is is
going to do it
yeah i think a lot of it is so i think
the three criteria as most people say
are founder so whether it's the right
founder whether it's a market that you
think is growing and also whether the
product is good in that market
uh in terms of the founder i think part
of it is education and then it's that
intangible side i think you can kind of
get it when you talk to them so it's
like dating right like someone might be
good on paper or like under tinder
profile it's like oh they're super
attractive
um
hey youtube
elbow me
that's you too nate come on it's every
single little criteria you want like oh
okay cool but like maybe when you're
talking to them the chemistry's not
there or you feel like they're not worth
your time yeah
interesting yeah so for the personal
side there's that um industry obviously
is that space growing is it something
that is in need of uh disruption or like
is like or maybe it's highly competitive
like if you're launching something
that sounds like a me too product then
that's very tough and then also the
product in that space how it does
relatively
jack do you have anything you seem like
you're going to invest
i kept sinking uh do i have any angel
investments yeah i've made one angel
investment in investment investment in
this company called good cash and uh i
saw the pitch last time carat the people
throwing this event why everybody is
here filming with us uh this guy pitched
and i liked the company and then i
remember i also i think i talked to you
a little bit about it and you and you
guys just said do it jack and i said
okay yeah i trust you guys so i did yeah
yeah he's a really smart kid oh yeah i
shouldn't call my kid but he's 18. so
he's like uh young adult super smart
yeah and i hear one other thing on angel
investing
usually when you're when you're buying
uh some private equity in these
companies
are you mostly placing a bet on the ceo
or depending on the founder and the it's
not necessarily the product yes because
they can they can pivot that's the thing
but like
are they able to execute if they need to
pivot end of the day like you're so
early that it has to be the person
interesting yeah yeah
you'd think that it would be the product
you really would so yeah here's the
thing though there's there's so many
companies that i pass on that are
outside of the venture world like there
was one just this week where the idea
was so good and i probably shouldn't
share it right now but it was such a
good idea and i'll share like off camera
um it was such a good idea but he just
wasn't an operator and you could tell
like based off of like his failed
businesses in the past and all these
other things and so
um yeah that's interesting but you love
the idea yeah and i was talking to chris
camillo yesterday about this and he's
like look if if they're not an operator
don't do it because even if the idea is
amazing it's a billion dollar idea if
they're not like if they just yeah
so because you're going to find some
questions it doesn't matter and you're
betting on the person sticking around
and making it a successful long-term
company
one wouldn't expect that at all you
think all it is is like the the product
or service because that's what you do
when you're investing in public
companies it's not like you're usually
considering the founder in that yeah so
for example good cash right like he by
himself
like the idea you could argue that maybe
it sounds like a me too copycat idea
because there's a lot of other companies
that do something similar but the fact
that he's just very smart and executing
and like
does the leg work to me matters yeah so
coming on next we have eric way he is
the co-ceo and founder of tri carrot the
company that's hosting this entire event
we've been friends with him for a super
long time he's the ceo of a business
valued in the nine figure range super
interesting guy we're gonna talk about
how he grew this business and a bunch of
other really cool stuff
you excited i am let's bring them on
eric welcome to the iced coffee hour
this is a long time coming i appreciate
it grandma jack i feel like i'm supposed
to know in dollar terms how much you've
generated
right that's usually how you frame it
yeah i actually
don't know i'm trying to remember let's
say 300 000. that's an accurate guess i
mean that's pretty good yeah i think
it's avoid like 220 230 no it's about
240 240. okay okay that's a good guess i
mean that's very accurate yeah that was
the classic really just throwing a
number out there and going with my gut
so a lot of people go in the millions
but it's it's about their wish so thank
you so much for coming on i think it's
important that we introduce you because
you are the founder and owner of the
credit card that i use all the time
uh we gotta listen to this hold on
the carriage credit card you gotta go
like that yeah
there we go this is the uh the heaviest
credit card that i have and you've
created this as a whole business of yes
running credit cards could you give us a
little bit of your backstory uh
a few minutes and how you came up with
this idea and and how this makes money
still i still don't understand how you
make money with this
so
my background is a mix of a couple of
different things i previously worked at
instagram as a product manager where i
helped build instagram live instagram
business and creator accounts products
for creator and condom businesses like
yourselves and i the time of my life
because i grew up
on youtube and twitch and getting to
build products and tools for the people
i had spent my entire high school and
college time watching
it just felt really special especially
and this goes into the other part i
doing of things i did before going to
instagram i previously worked in finance
i went to harvard i studied economics i
worked in investment banking at
blackstone i worked in management
consulting mckinsey and i was
absolutely miserable
is all things that i felt like i needed
to do because it's what everyone else
around me
was doing but it never actually was what
i wanted to do and so i went through a
period of my life i'd say my teens to my
mid-20s where i was very depressed
not really liking the direction i was
heading and watching a lot of youtube to
try and distance myself from it about
six years ago i had that existential
realization i had to make changes that's
why i left finance to go build products
for creators and now here at carat the
company i co-founded it brings it all
together because we build better
financial products for creators we've
worked with so many people for example
zhc who you've actually spoken with and
interviewed before one of the biggest
youtubers out there when he walks into a
bank and tries to explain what he does
for a living they don't actually get it
another individual you might be familiar
with ludwig
top streamer who when was doing his
subathon last year trying to gift subs
to people his card kept declining
because no bank trusted him enough to
give him a high enough limit the entire
financial system underwrites you off a
set of really standard metrics like fico
how much debt you've taken out in the
united states and how much you've paid
back it doesn't account for your actual
income your cash flow or if you're a
creator the size of your business and
your social stats so we're trying to
build the financial system for content
creator businesses
and as you said our first product is a
metal business card where we base its
terms limits and rewards off of those
social stats and you ask us how do we
make money
so the real secret for us we don't
charge any fees to the creators who use
our cards we make a little bit of money
called interchange which is the
processing fee that stores and merchants
pay to accept cards but the real play
is the cross sell
we believe that we're going to do such a
good job with these cards in building
our brand building our trust and
developing our own underwriting model to
actually assess whether creators are
good businesses that we're going to be
able to cross-sell them to other
financial products down the line like
bank accounts tax products
lines of capital even mortgages
the secret of financial technology
products it's always about the
cross-sell you're probably familiar with
the chase sapphire reserve card
the former head of chase jamie dimon
when asked how much money did you make
on this card because it was such a hit
he said
we lost 200 million dollars this year on
it and i wish we had lost 400 million
because all of the cost was incurred in
year one and all of the benefit is from
people who potentially might switch over
to other chase products over five six
seven years
so
our whole thinking at carat is we
started with a card which many top
creators like yourself use because it's
going to give us the ability to
cross-sell what we build next so i'll
pause there but sort of a really quick
high level on some of the things you ask
but you've been doing this credit card
now for two years
when is the next product
so three years actually but the reason
why i say two we spent one year just
failing repeatedly over and over and we
tried 15 different products one of them
was actually bookkeeping and taxes for
creators
and it's what we're launching next now
the difference is when we tried to do it
before
nobody knew who we were
and as a creator you think about taxes
maybe one percent of the time usually
you're focused on growing your channel
doing more content making more money and
the one percent of the time you care
about taxes everybody goes to the people
they already know and trust every
creator goes and finds hey you know my
mom's uncle's fraternity brother does
taxes for bakeries maybe he can help me
out so before in that year one we spent
an entire year trying to go to creators
saying you haven't heard of me but i can
do this better for you and everyone
either being that 99 percent of the time
they didn't care or that one person of
the time when they did they already were
like hey i know somebody who can do this
for me but the reason why we're
launching this now is because we
actually have that trust and we have the
ability to go down to people and say you
already use your cards now we can help
manage your accounting your tax strategy
your payroll so that's the really big
focus scram and jack that we actually
just launched about a month ago
who's doing that how do you vet these
people to make sure they're good so
there's really two three things you care
about when it comes to your bookkeeping
and your taxes
the first one is is it accurate aka if
it's not you might get audited by the
irs and there are so many creators we
work with
who are
issues where they owe back taxes and
penalties because they didn't have
someone helping them do it properly the
second thing is does it help you save
money
for example if we went and ordered
chipotle and started eating this here on
camera that potentially could be
considered a business expense and there
are many financial professionals out
there who don't know the sorts of white
house as creators that you can actually
get the third thing is responsiveness a
lot of times you're on your own
schedules both of you are so busy you
need someone who's managing your
finances to be available right away and
so many creators
they're so much busier
than normal small meeting businesses
that whoever they work with they're not
able to actually provide a high quality
service so on those three things making
sure you're not audited making sure
you're getting all the write-offs and
making sure it's responsive we actually
went and hired the accounting creator
specialists who were serving our card
holder clients
there were an entire team of people who
we were emailing back and forth because
we provided cards
to their clients and they'd ask us for
statements they'd ask us what is carrot
what is going on and one day we went to
them and said hey
do you want to just come work for us
because everything you're doing let's
put it under one roof where not only are
you going to help us provide the best
quality financial services to creators
we're also a tech company with engineers
we're going to take those insights and
start to build product around it too so
it's not just a peer services play for
us it's tech enabled it's using the
brand
and trust we've developed with cards
to hire the best people to now provide
financial services and start to build
product around automating more and more
of those pieces that's the focus now and
again what's our vision it's one day
every content creator business in the
world comes to us to incorporate to get
set up on cards accounts taxes credit
just everything and this is just one
small step toward getting there jack
really quick you pressed record on these
right yes okay
i was i was paranoid for a second
because i was like oh crap was i
supposed to do that here's what you're
doing so so here's something we're
breaking some news right here okay
we just wrapped up recording with jack
conte the the ceo of patreon yeah
what you didn't click record on those
the cameras weren't recording
we'll get them after this are you
no i'm serious i just wanted to get your
live reaction because i think it would
be kind of are you serious yes no yes
it's all right i can't tell if you're
messing because i mess with jack we're
going to bring jack back in and after
this he's still upstairs we'll make sure
are you kidding me jack don't don't mess
with me i'm not kidding no no because
remember how i ran in because you were
already in here
i just assumed that you already clicked
record on them yeah i saw you messing
with this thing yeah i mean i turned
this on you don't know how to use that
are you you swear jack you have to
i swear i swear i swear in your family i
swear in my family that's a really high
state screwed up
really yeah what do we do it's fine
i'm not bothered by it we could just try
again
it's okay graham no but that was so good
the first time i know it was really good
but we can get it again
now you have an even deeper friendship
and you know jack and i'm sure he's
gonna want to come down we have another
pitch coming up after that we can go
grab punch and right now we have eric
from tricara who has what's the
evaluation like 400 million really high
and it's actually
confidential for reasons that i'll tell
you afterwards but suffice it to say is
we build a product a lot of creators
love and we've raised a lot of money
and
i'll also say the whole reason why we
brought jack in
and for those who are watching and
listening who might have the comics is
jack conte the founder and ceo of
patreon who's a fellow judge with graham
here on the whole creator shark tank
show we're putting together the reason
why we brought in jack and why i'm
excited to bring him back down have him
record is because that guy is the great
example one of the first tech ceos who's
also a creator because he's also a
musician jack i think is actually one of
the first ceos who's also a creator so
we're in a way i'm just trying to follow
in his footsteps and this is our way of
creating by hosting events like this
let's talk a little bit about this event
specifically because i know with your
card you throw a lot of like different
parties and events and then invite every
every creator and it's one of my
favorite things about the card honestly
it's the community that you guys
facilitate the perks of the card are
obviously they're great i love the cash
back and everything yeah and always like
the fact that it's metal totally awesome
i love the events that you guys throw
and uh let's talk about this one
specifically we've done one like this in
the past where it's like a shark tank
kind of but instead of the sharks it's
just a bunch of really good creators and
then you bring in other people what's
like the purpose behind these events i'm
sure that they're not cheap
so we once got dinner with max election
the co-founder of paypal and she told us
the most important thing around
financial products and acquisition it's
actually trust
think about the financial products you
use i know for myself the bank i'm on is
the one my mom set up for me when i was
10 years old
in order to do something different and
something new you have to have a lot of
trust in that new company and what
you're doing and we're building
something really new financial products
for creators the trust and awareness and
education piece is actually the most
important we're not trying to say hey
we're better than all of the other
products out there we're trying to say
hey as a creator you should care about
these things period because you're not
just a creator and a creative you're
also a business who deserves and needs
to be set up on business products so an
event like this one creator shark tank
it's about helping everybody and
yourselves see yourselves
as businesses as entrepreneurs as ceos
of your own media empires and as
investors who other companies are coming
in asking for your expertise to help
i know you've spoken with minx as well
and
minx joined because when i chatted with
her on discord and i said hey i think
you'd be fantastic as a judge on a
creator shark tank she said hey you know
like i don't know if this is really my
style and i said this is a chance to
show to the world that you're not just
funny you're smart
and we get
and our mission is carrot to elevate you
so the rest of the world sees you the
same way we do
as business people so we host things
like this because it builds trust and
awareness and it aligns with our mission
where instead of watching mark cuban and
kevin o'leary you get to watch people
and personalities who've built
followings of millions who inspire
entertain and educate
come in a different context
as business people
one thing that i found kind of
interesting is how you mentioned a
mission of the company how many
employees do you currently have so we
have about 50 employees right now 50
employees and we recently had laila
hormozy on the podcast and she was
mentioning how you can develop a good
culture around the business yes because
you know she has her her startup i guess
as well and she said the most important
thing in order to create a culture
around a business and to get good
hard-working employees
is you have to establish a mission and
like a core goal basically that
that the company is trying to achieve
and then beneath that what did she say
there was it was values
i don't remember i think it was a
mission you have to establish a mission
and then you have to think about every
action and value and make sure that
every action and value of the the
employees is serving that mission
somehow how do you how do you establish
a culture within your business
and how do you find good people to try
to emulate that culture first of all
absolutely love alex and layla second
the reason why you need a mission even
is looking at super tactical as a
startup why would somebody come work for
us when they could just go to work for
facebook and get paid multiple times
more and probably work less the only
reason they would is they might be
really lined on liking us as people they
might be excited by the prospect of
building an earliest hitch company with
a chance at upside b
part of it is going to be the mission
it's the
why
are you even a thing why do you even
exist
and when you bring jack you should ask
him about is we actually share a very
similar mission to jack where he's
described it as empowering the second
renaissance right many of you are
familiar with the first renaissance
which was a blossoming of intellectual
and creative energy
and thinking is there's going to be
another because when you've made it
easier than ever for people to create
content and share with each other
there's going to be a moment where the
younger generations they're all growing
up they want to be creators making
content like this for them is going to
be as simple and easy as breathing and
then when everybody feels comfortable
sharing and creating content with each
other at a certain point there's not
going to be like a singularity moment
where boom there's going to be another
inflection point in terms of humanity
benefiting from everyone sharing and
learning amongst themselves
and so in a way the mission of companies
like patreon and ourselves is to
empower the creators and help make that
happen and the way we see it as a
creator there's a lot of things you have
to do on figuring out how to make
content how to find your community how
to make money from it we're the ones
that want to help you scale it into a
business
anything involving the hard work around
managing your flows of money
working with the financial system
working with the government we want to
make that easy so you get to continue
focusing on the creative piece
that's not only our mission it's also
why i started carrot the best part of
what i get to do
is spending time with people like both
of you genuinely appreciating and
admiring what you've built and just
thinking through from my side is there
something i can do to make that better
the impetus behind our very product like
i said is people like zhc people like
ludwig who were just suffering really
low limits hit by really arbitrary banks
and that's what informed the decision go
build that out and everything we're
doing after is based on what you think
is important do you worry though that
these banks have these systems in there
for a reason they've been around for a
very long time and by breaking some of
those reasons that maybe you're opening
yourself up to some sort of issue let's
say if a creator charges up the card
all of a sudden their ad revenue goes
down a sponsor doesn't come through and
then they're in a position like oh crap
i spent 100 grand and i got 20k yeah
don't worry about that that's a higher
likelihood of happening here so the risk
and reward come hand in hand people
often ask oh i assume in starting this
company you must have figured out a way
to minimize defaults no we have defaults
absolutely it's
why there's no free lunch it's why
nobody's built something like this
before you can't go and underwrite a
brand new population without incurring
the risk and learnings around figuring
out oh here's somebody who i thought was
good and they actually weren't
and the only way to build an
underwriting model and build financial
products for new population is to say
i'm going to underwrite people who i
think might default because if you only
underwrite the people who you think are
good you're just hard-coding your own
assumptions
you're not actually learning
so
the really long answer to your point
gram is it's absolutely risky and big
banks don't do it because they already
have a proven business model on serving
the lowest common denominator of your
average american
and what's changing now is financial
technology products are becoming easier
and easier to build which means you get
to specialize and build it to solve
specific problems for specific types of
people you've probably noticed chime and
step for example build to solve problems
for young adults and teenagers nova
credit is focused on solving the
problems of immigrants there's ones
doing that for uber drivers and
freelancers we're doing that for
creators and yes in underwriting that
new population you will face more
defaults because you're taking on an
area that people haven't yet understood
but the hope is if you can learn fast
enough
you now have built a moat that stops
anybody else from coming in in terms of
not only the trust you've built from a
brand pov but literally your
underwriting models can be better than
anybody else's because you've now
learned what actually matters and what
doesn't so who defaults could you give
us like maybe some factors that would
play into that like creators who uh make
riskier content or creators with under x
amount of subscribers so metric i frame
it as
where were the areas or populations that
we had to learn the most because we knew
the least
and
it's creators who have now begun to
expand their business models beyond just
making money from say adsense or
sponsorship revenue it's folks who have
built content businesses were saying now
they're selling products
and there's inventory risk right then
there's a potential outcome where they
didn't necessarily know how well they
were going to sell and it didn't end up
being as strong as they thought it would
and those were some of the cases where
we saw as hey we know this is a riskier
segment the upside is also potentially
larger too and we want to go learn and
see how we can underwrite it's probably
the same calculus that both of you think
about as creators right when you've
decided for example to launch a line of
courses that was a little bit more risk
for a little bit more reward you've
actually spoken on your channel about
launching your coffee business and the
risks and expenses and tribulations
you've gone through are frankly probably
an order of magnitude more complex and
harder than if you stuck to just doing
content but you do it because there's
also more potential reward so i think of
it less as who's more likely to fault
and more on what are the segments that
we realized we had to learn more to
comfortably underwrite because their
business models were different
and growing beyond the traditional hey i
make content and i get adsense and i get
sponsorship revenue
okay so it's the night before posting
but we can't forget about giving a
verbal shout out to our patrons we got
to shout out ben ashmore rich smith
colin l enam khan with inom from
investing or investing with inom
rick barkley and kevin dunkle thank you
guys so much for
being patrons